[Music]
thank you for joining us fighting has
erupted in the occupied West Bank after
Israeli forces launched an operation
against a Palestinian armed group called
The Lion's Den the occupation forces
entered the old town of Nablus on Monday
nights walking protests at least four
people have been killed in Nablus and
one near Amala another 21 have been
injured they've been power Cuts in parts
of the city demonstrations have also
been reported in Ramallah Ibrahim has
more from Ramallah
it's important to point out that the
lion then has had a lot of support by
Palestinians dating we've seen
Palestinians praising them those groups
of people are opposed a challenge to
Israel not only because they are young
men who say that Israel only understands
the language of food sometimes going
inside Israel or to confrontation points
and carrying now truth and attacks
against Israel but also because they are
cross-factional they're from different
Palestinian fractions they are mobilized
in a way that's hard for Israel to
penetrate and we've seen an increase in
the Israeli measures to try and track
down the Lions then the city of nebulous
has been under siege for more than two
weeks so we know that the pension is
high we are approaching these really
elections this is a time when many thing
in analytics will tell you Israel we try
to show that it has an iron fist that
it's trying to
win more votes by appealing to the
right-wing voters in Israel and by
showing that they are cracking down on
any military activities by the
Palestinians
so what do we know about the Palestinian
group The Lion's Den well members of the
Armed group first appeared in public in
Nablus in the occupied West Bank last
month they recited what they called a
charter of resistance during a memorial
service for two Palestinians killed by
Israeli forces since then the Lion's Den
has claimed responsibility for a number
of attacks on Military checkpoints and
illegal settlements in Nablus Ibrahim
yunus is a media coordinator for the
Palestinian youth movement he says
Alliance then armed group emerged from
an urgent need to protect the occupied
territories
to understand the the perspective of
Palestinian youth in the West Bank you
have to look at a situation where
there's uh 800 000 settlers who are
illegally occupying
um a great percentage of the land there
you have constant daily attacks on
Palestinian youth who are whether
they're Crossing checkpoints whether
they're walking to school or to work uh
the number of young Palestinians run
over by cars or attacked by settlers is
large so obviously there's going to be a
lot of popularity among youth in the
West Bank when a group uh says that
they're not going to accept the presence
of these settlers on their land
uh they emerged out of a group of Youth
who defend the city essentially from
Israeli incursions and uh decided to
create a more formal group that would
defend the city which is where the group
name and organizational structure sort
of emerged uh they do not have a working
relationship with the Palestinian
Authority so the Palestinian Authority
at the higher levels collaborates uh
with or coordinates security with with
Israel and uh the Lions Den uh does not
so they do not have a formal
relationship